2019 is shaping up to be a year of
historic flooding in several parts of
the united states
early flooding in march impacted several
communities along the missouri and
mississippi rivers
this region features 59 of the nation's
corn producing farmland which produces
roughly 67 of the nation's corn output
the national oceanic and atmospheric
agency expects flooding to continue
through may
noaa's spring 2019 outlook identified
the major reasons for this year's
historic flooding so let's run through
four of the big ones
okay breaking news more rain means more
flooding as the weather warms up heading
into april the atmosphere retains more
moisture
which leads to more rain
we've had an abnormal year when it comes
to precipitation
through the through the winter months
this past winter season
we saw it to 200 of normal
as far as precipitation so we've got a
lot of snow water equivalent sitting on
the ground snow water equivalent is the
amount of leftover water if an entire
unit of snow were to melt
reason number two excess amounts of snow
in late winter several portions of the
midwest experienced something called
obamagenesis
you get this
storm system and it was like a
bombogenesis that came through
jumped out into the plains it produced
hurricane force winds across the central
part of the country so you had the
battle of the warm air in the cold air
uh you had that warm air was expecting
up it was melting that snow that was
ready to release
on the back side of it you had you know
snow and those still hurricane force
winds
and
turned into blizzard conditions
that weather pattern of extreme cold
followed by relatively extreme heat
further exacerbated flooding
reason number three frozen ground and
fully saturated soils
that extreme cold caused another problem
the top soil froze which made the ground
less permeable like concrete
water that would usually absorb into the
dirt had nowhere else to go
this is the same concept that makes
cities with vast networks of roads more
susceptible to flooding we had this you
know a lot of precipitation in the form
of rain
prior to it freezing so i mean that that
ground is saturated to a certain level
the freeze depth will will grow just
like that we see the ice on the river
systems and what happens when uh when
that ground actually freezes
it becomes a hard surface so any rain
that falls on it it just shoots it right
off rain on top of snow on top of frozen
ground and it it's just a perfect
combination for
a flooding event
the soil along the missouri river a
significant hot spot of flooding this
year doesn't irrigate easily
the weather across the midwest also led
to excessive ice deposits
these large chunks of ice can eventually
jam up the free flow of water down river
like a natural dam
when the river is jammed flood waters
can temporarily overspill even further
onto farms or other property
some farmers were left waiting for days
or even weeks for flood waters to recede
from their property
so what's the impact
for farming communities along the
missouri river think nebraska iowa south
dakota the impact is substantial the
flooding comes at the beginning of
planting season for many of the farmers
in the region and some farmers are still
waiting to survey the damage done as
flood waters recede
these delays will carry big implications
for the entire agribusiness supply chain
flood water has contaminated some of
what was in farmers grain bins which
could mean some fairly substantial
losses for farmers
delays in the beginning of planting
season also may prompt farmers to plant
soybeans rather than corn because
soybeans can be planted later
also transportation networks are running
slower due to the flooding
that may impede the agribusiness supply
chain as shipments stall while flood
waters recede from obstructed roads or
rail lines
compared to this time last year there
were 14 percent less grain car loads in
transport
grain barge movements were also down
about 31 compared to this time last year
the impact of the slowdown is already
weighing on grain traders one company
told the journal that flooding would cut
its first quarter operating profit by up
to 60 million dollars
the slowdowns are even reaching into the
energy sector as the supply of corn
slows down gasoline prices are up seven
percent compared to the same time last
year
the national weather service cautiously
notes that the worst of flood season may
be in the rear view mirror i i hate to
say this
we might have seen the worst by now
but the impact of the flooding from
early march will be felt for months to
come